[Music]
you are never gonna guess what happened
to me the other day
i was here at my desk late one night
getting my work done when all of a
sudden
you know what the security cameras were
on and they caught the whole thing
see for yourself
i have entirely too many knick-knacks at
my desk
oh my god take whatever you want just
don't hurt my frogs
what frogs do people have frogs instead
of babies now
i knew things would be different in the
future but i didn't know they'd be that
wild
what year is it uh 2020. oh
yes yes i did it we said i had a yeah
what did we do i time traveled but
instead of traveling back in time like
some [ __ ]
i travel 200 years into the future
because i already know that the past is
bad because i was there
so tell me about now tell me how good
2020 is my sister
uh i don't want to you know like
overload you
okay well in 1793 i was a slave with no
rights
george washington was my master and let
me tell you i have seen some [ __ ]
so can i get new teeth here not without
insurance
look you must be hungry if you traveled
all the way from the
past do you want to eat something i have
some fresh fruits and oats from the
market
that's the same [ __ ] i was eating before
ain't you free don't you eat cake every
day
no i can't have carbs but you know what
yeah
technically we can eat whatever we want
now no slave masters or advertisers tell
us what to eat we are free to do
whatever we want ah
thank god so black women are finally
free
and i didn't say all that it depends on
what you mean by free
well i mean at the core of it there's
not a group of white men running around
killing black folks even if they didn't
do anything wrong
right they don't really travel around in
packs anymore
there's usually just one lone wolf but
unfortunately yeah they still do that
sometimes they even get paid leave for
it oh god
but we can vote right i was right there
cleaning up the white house when
congress came to be
all those terrible men in charge can i
see a picture of congress now
i said show me a photo of congress now
not from 1793
that's all old white people this is
congress now
it's still all old white people oh no no
no
everything is still the same well can i
at least eat the feast of the poor
lobsters oxtail avocado rich people
co-opted that food
lobster oxtail avocado toast all in one
day that's like
150 in new york so let me get this
straight
congress is still all white white people
can kill us with no consequences
they stole all our recipes and every
person has to have all this frog [ __ ]
yes and the frog thing also
yes well can i at least take a walk
outside for some fresh air
you can't just be breathing outside the
air is actually very bad now
and even if the air was okay there's a
deadly virus that can be transmitted
through our breathing
i'm just gonna i get it
is everyone okay oh thank god
love you
dear diary i saw me
[Music]
you